Next, hit time is affected
by having to access the TLB
before we access the cache.
Remember that the processor starts
out with the virtual address.
We use some part of that virtual
address to index into the TLB and
find the frame number.
We then combine that with the page
offset and now that we have the physical
address, we can use it to access
our cache and get the data from it.
So really,
if the TLB takes one cycle and
the cache takes one cycle, we need two
cycles from when the processor gives us
the address until we
actually get the data.
Because really the TLB access and
the cache access have to
happen one after the other.
A cache that is accessed using a
physical address is called a physically
accessed cache, a physical cache, and
also it is called physically indexed or
physically tagged or PIPT cache.
The overall hit latency of that cache
really is the TLB hit latency and
the cache hit latency.